America's Elite universities have turned
into billion dollar hedge funds and at
the top of the list is Harvard with a
hedge fund of 51 billion dollars with
that big of a hedge fund Harvard could
pay the 55 000 tuition for every single
student literally forever but we all
know this is never going to happen and
of course they don't actually call it a
hedge fund they had to give it a vague
innocent sounding name like endowments
but the reality is endowments aren't
about education or supporting students
no it's all about enriching the academic
Elite while drowning students in more
and more debt while you're slaving away
at a job you hate to pay off your
student loans the heads of these
colleges are getting insanely rich off
of these hedge funds while asking
parents for more donations every single
year click the link in the pinned
comment to learn how the world really
works